Hello, everybody. How is everybody today?
I have some exciting information to share about a new diet that we're going to be implementing with a number of you.
It's called the FMD, which stands for Fasting Mimicking Diet.
Fasting Mimicking Diet. That's what we're going to be talking about today.
Now, it's only a short-term diet just not to scare you. Everybody gets scared with that D word,
but it's a diet that can be implemented. It's supposed to be implemented five days of every month
for three months and then off for three months and then you do it again.
So, it's done six times a year then. That would be the normal progression of this diet for only five days each time.
So, it is not something that you stay on long-term. It is actually a kit that you see in this picture right here,
but we will go over it in detail in this presentation.
So, a Fasting Mimicking Diet is based on getting your body in a Fasting State.
So, in a Fasting State, these slides are taken from the University of Southern California,
so give them credit for that. But in a Fasting State, we talk about the evolution of a Fast.
In the past, we were depended upon hunt and harvest, and even though I'm about an evolutionist,
per se, you could even say a Biblical times. There was times that we went where we didn't have
a lot to eat. So, there was days that you didn't have a lot to eat and there was benefit of that.
Even in Biblical times, Fasting was something that was done for religious purposes on a very regular
basis. So, these patterns of Fasting or lack of food forced our body to be able to survive during
periods of hunger. And there's huge benefits to going through this, but it's very difficult.
So, there's new concept that actually makes it much better that that's what this Fasting Mimicking
Diet is all about. When food is scarce, when we're not eating, the body acts to conserve energy,
and it diminishes, it decreases, it down-regulates multiple pathways. And some of the key nutrient pathways
that it down-regulates is the PKA pathway, the M-tore pathway, and the IGF-1 pathway. Now, these are
all pathways that are highly inflammatory, and that are up-regulated with cancer patients.
So, this type of diet fits perfectly with cancer patients. There's multiple clinical trials
going on right now with cancer patients and this diet, and they're all coming back promising. It's
really, really cool. So, these pathways you've heard me speak about in multiple other presentations,
things that we're trying to down-regulate. Well, Fasting Mimicking Diet, the FMD diet,
down-regulates these pathways. So, it's really, really exciting. So, Fasting is actually a company
by an increase in desire to move. You think, oh, if I get a fast, I'm going to be just groggy
on the couch, but actually, when we're hungry, we want to get out and find food. So, it actually
is a great kind of stimulation for our body. So, but the problem is, again, it's difficult. So,
the body identifies the presence of food through these specific nutrient-sensit pathways.
So, down-regulated these pathways, especially the IGF1, the MTOR, and the PKA pathways,
basically, starves cancer. Now, this isn't just for cancer. The studies are also an autoimmune
disease, MS, Lyme disease, some studies that are, I've covered on Lyme disease, but any neural
degeneration, Alzheimer's, and Parkinson's, it's unbelievable, the results that are coming back on
these. But the difficult thing about Fasting, the difficult thing about staying away from food is that
it's hard to get somebody to do it. It's not easy, and it's not always safe for periods of time,
because if I'm completely staying away from food out of water fast, that will down-regulate those
pathways. But the problem is, my body will kick into what's called gluconeogenesis, and I'll break
down proteins in order to make glucose. So, I'll actually start breaking down my muscle cells
in order to start making glucose to feed the glucose nutrients in my body, or the glucose
depended cells in my body, including the cancer cells. So, that's where the FFFD diet comes in.
This is the doctor who discovered it. I actually met him this weekend. He's a great guy.
He's the one who's pioneered all this research through the University of Southern California.
Tons of money has been poured into this research, and it's just some really cool stuff.
This time of this video, it is in December. His book is not coming out till January. So,
it is a pre-sale on Amazon if you want to grab it. Look, you have to look up his name there because I
forgot this slide presentation to copy and paste a picture of his book on here.
So, fasted, mimicking diets, FMDs, down-regulate the body's key nutrient-sensit pathways, and these
are key pathways for cell replication. That's how your body heals, remember, through that whole
MTOR pathway, and that's how your body creates replication cycles through that MTOR pathway.
The MTOR pathway is what's up-regulated with cancer patients. So, if we can down-regulate the MTOR
pathway, we are decreasing the cancer's ability to replicate. So, using a very, very specific combination
of low protein, low carbohydrates, and low sugars, and some fat, FMDs help to move food into the
body without releasing any of the signaling factors. So, doing the FMD diet, you can continue to take
supplements, but you cannot continue to take any green drinks. No other foods, no cheating on this.
So, the stomach sees the nutrients that we're putting in there, and they're very specific.
We have to stick to it in detail with what's in the box, and I'll show you that in a little bit.
But, for those five days, it can change that whole system, and the argument is, well, great,
if it changes, if a down-regulates, my MTOR and IGF and PKA pathways for five days,
that's wonderful. Well, what happens after that? Well, that's the really cool thing about this,
is that it keeps them down-regulated for a long period of time. The testing,
though, on all the studies that you were going to see in just a little bit, all the studies were done
doing five days a month, for three months. So, that's only three cycles of five days of the FMD,
once a month, for three months, and the studies, all the labs were run on these patients out six
months, and they still showed low growth factor tests, low MTOR testing, and all the other
parameters that they were testing still maintained low, going back on a good healthy diet, which I have
you guys on already. So, you don't go back and eat hamburgers, but you're going back to eat what
I already have tested you on. So, you're foregoing the diet that I gave you for five days,
going on a FMD diet for five days, once a month, for three months, and then going back at the end of
that five days to the diet that I gave you. So, is it difficult for five days? Well, it's not going to
be as easy as eating normally, but you're given food to give you satiation of your appetite.
Normally, people are eating normal foods, which are technically high in protein, high in sugar,
high in carbohydrates, if you live in the United States. Even the diets that you're on are relatively
high in these things. Well, you could say I'm not eating any sugar, any carbs,
where you're really vegetables, so you're getting carbs, and that's breaking down to sugar.
That up regulates IGF1, up regulates insulin, up regulates, mTOR, up regulates the PKA pathway,
and it up regulates cancer growth, it up regulates immune response to an auto-immune disease
with Lyme disease, etc. The five-day FMD is very low-protein, very low sugar, very low carbs,
but not to the point that's going to stimulate glucodiogenesis. That's the key to this. If we just do a
five-day water fast, that could be great, but it can stimulate glucodiogenesis, and we negate the
benefits of the water fast. So we have to stay within a parameter that we are decreasing the IGF1
insulin response, mTOR, and the PKA. So we're going to optimize aging, we're going to optimize a
decrease in autoimmune response, we're going to optimize a decrease in cancer growth.
And again, as I said, how these work, you're on it for five days, and there's different phases
that your body's going through. The first couple days, it's called an induction phase on how
your body's starting to respond to this, then you start to get cellular protection mode,
DNA and stem cell primed what they found, and then rejuvenation and regeneration goes on
from that point on. And like I said, the studies were measured out six months.
So I want to do a cycle of once a month for five days, for three months. So you're doing three
of these, and then off for three months, you're staying on the regular diet for three months that I
gave you, and if you're doing well, you could choose not to do it again. But if you want to, again,
prime the system, again, to keep in that low m-tore, stimulating function of your body,
then we want to do it again for three months. So you would do six cycles of these a year if you
really want to optimize your chances to reducing m-tore and IGF at PKA levels. It's very exciting
for a lot of patients, not only cancer and live patients, it's very exciting for a lot of patients.
There are numerous studies, and I don't have time to go over all of them, but there is numerous studies
done through USC on this, on what it does to visceral fat, and you know that visceral fat is where we
hold our toxins. What it does with neurogenesis, there's more and more studies on neurogenesis coming
out because of Alzheimer's and Parkinson's and MS. It reduces autoimmunity, it alleviates MS symptoms,
there's show that all other goendercytes are regenerated through this diet. It's really, really
interesting. So anybody with brain cancer, this is a great diet for them. Matter of fact they
compared this diet to a ketogenic diet with MS patients, and ketogenic diet did much better than the
control diet. The control is in red, ketogenic is in the dark blue. In every factor except one where
it was near equal, the FMD did much better, sometimes three times better, than the ketogenic diet.
So ketogenic diet is much harder to stay on and you're having to stay on that constantly. So doing a
more keto-like diet for the MS and brain cancer patients, while doing this once a month, for three
months, it would be much easier to do than to try to stay at a full ketogenic diet and full ketosis for
that, for basically for life. So this is a much easier thing to do. There's also a process that's called
immuno-subestance. Immuno-subestance speaks of as we age our immune system decreases.
And as we age we end up getting a shift in our lymphoid to myeloid ratio. This is a type of white
blood cell. Excuse me that we have. That is why we get an increase in AML diseases as we age.
AML is a type of leukemia. So this would be a perfect diet for all AML and lymphoma patients as well.
That shift to myeloid shift in the lymphoid to myeloid ratio is called immuno-subestance. And that is
one of the theories on why cancer increases as we age. The rate of cancer increases as we age.
So that's obviously not true in all cancers, but it does fit this whole piece.
Doing a functional medicine or a function, an FMD diet with myeloid type patients, meaning
multiple myeloamia patients, AML patients, and lymphoma patients, FMD diet affects the stem cells.
We're not talking about circulated tumor cells, but the healthy stem cells. And it creates a shift
back, giving a healthier ratio, that lymphoid to myeloid ratio. And that was really neat and
very promising for the leukemia patients. There's multiple studies with FMD and cancer that I can't
go over. Unfortunately, most of those studies, the way they're getting funded, are they're using
it with chemotherapy. But it's really cool. And if you're currently on chemotherapy, we need to speak
individually about this because there's a little bit different parameter on how you do it.
But a decreased calorie intake on an FMD diet is shown to not only decrease IGF1, it decreases insulin,
it increases cortisol, it decreases sex hormones, which can drive cancer. So any cancers that are
hormone driven, so any prostate, any breast cancer, any ovarian cancer, any uterine cancer,
this is a perfect diet for this. It decreases oxidative stress, decreases inflammation.
So it's the studies are very, very promising on this.
The thing with cancer is there's what's called a differential stress resistance in cancer,
normal cells. If you go on an FMD diet, short-term decreased calorie diet, the cells are protected.
But tumor cells don't have that same protection and tumor cells then decrease growth and die.
So it is an excellent diet for all forms of cancer, except childhood cancers. It's very difficult
to do this with a child. So the the trials have been extremely promising. They've been shown
to be fantastic for diabetes, for coronary vascular disease, for cancer, and just to help with
aging and to decrease the symptoms of aging arthritis and amino citizens.
So this is just more data on what has done on these clinical trials. I remember these were all
done over. This is the final after six months of trial, when these people only did it three times.
So decreased body weight, the darker color here is after the six months, the lighter color is how
they began. Decrease of abdominal fat, waist circumference, lead body mass, decreased IGF-1 levels,
blood pressure levels, cholesterol, C-reactive protein, which is an immune marker,
and healthy stem cells. So I'm very excited, obviously, about this and it helping a lot of my
patients. I get to be going to this diet, so I will report to you what I feel also has a lot of
benefits beyond cancer and beyond any brain issues and autoimmune issues and live issues.
But understand, you're on the diet for five days and it is each day there's a box in the kit for
what you are going to eat. It's all powdered and you're going to use that for five days. I have
tasted some of it already and it's great. So I'm excited about it. Again, you're on it for five days,
once a month for three cycles and in between that, you go back to your normal diet, the diet that I
have given you. Interest in with these patients of the study, they were put on any other special diet
at all. They were their normal diet, which some of them were pretty crappy. So I'm sure,
just like a general cohort study, a population group, some people normally eat real well and some
people don't eat real well and still the results show that. It's not giving you who knows to eat
whatever you want, but going back to the diet that I gave you, I'm really excited what we're going to
see in this. This is what it looks like. It comes with a box in the box in the large box. There's
five boxes with an instruction manual and there is, you take out box number one for day one.
Each one of the days are slightly different and it is engineered specifically
to diminish and reduce any gluconeogenesis. So you have to follow it to a T. You can take your other
supplements with it. You have to. I want you to. And this is going to be done at an individual
basis. You need to consult with me. You don't just purchase this from our store. Now I purchased
these at a discount. You can go on prologue's website. That's the website right there at the
name of the company. You can see it. Prologue and you can see a video and you can see a bunch of
information and you could theoretically purchase it from them. A kit from them, three kits from them
and do this. I get a discount and I'm passing the discount on to my patients. So I'm not looking
to make a penny off of this. So it's better to get it from me and if you're by patient, I want to
make sure I watch you through this so that you're not just jumping into this. Now this video is
going out to a lot of people that may watch this and you have to do it with your doctor. So I suggest
highly that you get doctors approval and you do this in a company and by being tested and being
checked and making sure that you're speaking with your doctor. So the kit comes with the five
small boxes. They're all plant-based. They're all organic. They're all no additives, coloring,
nothing like that. So I checked all that out. The ingredients give you about 800 to 1100 calories a day
that will keep you from glucodiogenesis and I tasted a couple of the bars. They were actually really
super good and you follow it for five days and then you're back on your regular diet and you do that
again in one month. So you've got to time this you know around family gatherings and things like
that and so that you can make sure that you get it on your calendar that you can do this.
Set up an appointment with me to talk about this. It may not be appropriate for you. There are some
precautions. You you you want to be careful of that and go ahead and read these. Obviously it says
don't operate motor vehicles yachting on and they say that with everything but you know you might be
a little bit more light-headed. Your calorie restriction is going to is dropped down. You might be
used to eating 2,000 calories a day or more dropping down to 800. May make a difference. Typically people
are not more tired but we like I said but you may experience those things that you just have to be
careful of that. There is some exclusions people that can be that should be excluded
out of this. So I'll let you read these. Children are going to be excluded out of this. Women who are
pregnant and they're seen if you have allergies to nuts or soy because there is some of that in
there in order to get to that specific calorie counted everything so that would eliminate you.
So again contact me. I'm excited about this and using this for some of our patients. So contact me
and set up an appointment. All right hopefully this is very helpful and I just pray that this is
going to be a blessing to a lot of our patients. Bye-bye.